I think they're going to have a few bigger girls in this issue too
bigger girl. Like a Latifa, no. Ashley Gray hammers in their home.
Ashley Gray. Oh, she's a real pig. I don't know what that is. I'm joking,
but he's at bigger girls.
I don't know who that is. I don't think she took that one. Well,
[inaudible] gray ham,
grain. Ham. She's a real pig. She's a
dude is not having it. [inaudible] Oh, she's beautiful.
Full figured gal. And she's a bit on the big side, but she's nice.
That's a little, a little he's nicely for me. Yeah. Yeah.
You can tell when you're slapped, but it rolls.
I can with you guys joking. I love to eat her out. My mom's calling me.
All right. Good for her going. Every guy you don't want every guy gone.
Yeah. That's you know, that's, that's great. But see, I don't what,
what bothers me is all right. We all have to accept this. Hey, she's hot. Yeah.
Yeah. But if a guy was five, four comes in, everybody makes one of them,
you know, we gotta have it both ways. I got the five, four. It got,
I can't get any love. Right.
Thanks for the support fellows. All right.
So we got chunky gals that's we got to high five her,
but how about the bald guy? Nothing. I, you know, where does it end?
Let's see the 58 geezer. Yes.
I didn't see that coming at all. I liked it. I think it looks amazing. Oh,
you're lying. The little chest freckles.
The face I was in with the face. I'll be honest with you.
I was just with a nice body, but then the, uh, you don't like the bond,
the pullout. I mean, it's, it looks like a lady to see it, the remodel pool.
I'm not going to, not against that.
To notice that they shot her at the end of the day, when the sun was going,
[inaudible] give me a dirty look. I'm not having it. I'm sorry, Nina.
I just don't know. Where does it end? Are we going to go wheelchair? You know,
there has to be some standard is all I'm saying all women are beautiful. Wow.
What I mean, come on. That doesn't make sense in different ways.
The definition of the word. Beautiful. It means there's only a few, you know,
sports. Hill's straight. I got to say, uh, the swimsuit issue is probably the,
the only magazine I, I still buy. Yeah, no, I'm serious.
It's probably the only one I still buy. Well, you can collect, you know, herb,
I don't need to collect them. Right. I'll take
[inaudible]. I get that way with guns and ammo.
So I don't really get your jokes to be honest,
most bottles don't.